armelle charrier bonjour je me tourne
vers vous personne n'est dans la tête de
vladimir poutine bien sûr mais quelles
sont les options envisageables
aujourd'hui se dirige-t-on vers une
guerre ouverte ou au contraire peut-on
imaginer qu'après cette intervention on
se retrouve dans une sorte de statu quo
avec un conflit gelé à à la géorgienne
par exemple en fait la question
fondamentale c'est la question de la
guerre ouverte et tout le monde
j'imagine que vladimir poutine va
s'arrêter là parce qu'il n'a pas grand
chose à gagner en fait ça allait
s'emparer d'une partie de la de
l'ukraine aujourd'hui il est encore dans
une phase de négociation parce que
quelque part l'opération qu'il a menées
sur ces républiques séparatistes
on voit bien sûr n'a la carte permet en
fait de rester justement d'en dire
regardez je m'occupe que de soutenir les
rebelles et en fait ils occupent juste
la ligne va aller jusqu'à la ligne de
front qui de toutes manières depuis des
années est en conflit et ses 6 passes
derrière que dans ces cas là il va
mordre réellement sur l'ukraine telle
qu'on imagine aujourd'hui ou alors s'il
va un peu plus bas et qu'on le verra
aller vers marioupol qui est un porc
d'ukraine qui est très symbolique
effectivement donc c'est tout là dessus
qu'on est en train de jouer cela dit
comme il continue en permanence à dire
que les négociations sont ouvertes et
qu'on voit que pendant la nuit a fait
une invasion spectaculaire forcément on
se rend compte qu'on a encore ce temps
de négociation avec vladimir poutine et
qu'il est plus en fait en train
impressionné mais on n'est pas à l'abri
d'un changement d'un berry davie où on
n'est pas à l'abri d'une escarmouche
vous restez avec nous à armel